én szoktam mondani ezt egy nagyon kedves
barátnőm mondta régebb hogy hogy az ő
nagymamája mindig azt mondta neki hogy
ne úgy gondolj a dolgokra mint amik
veled történnek hanem úgy mint amik
értett történnek valami nagyon
nehézségben van az ember és ez tényleg
lehet egy egy valami nagyon-nagyon
borzalmas nagy nehézség tudok-e tudok-e
úgy gondolni rá vagy úgy tudom-e úgy
megélni azt hogy rendben egyrészt tudni
azt hogy ez ez csak időszakosüüm
másrészt mit tudok tanulni ebből hogyan
figyelni igen igen figyelni igen nem
csak nem csakzív
igen pontosan nem csak áldozata lenni és
akkor felvenni teljesen ezt az
áldozatmatartást hogy hát persze hogy
velem történik és hogy hogy akkor akkor
így megadni magad ennek vagy pedig vagy
pedig tényleg azt mondani hogy hogy mit
tudok ebből tanulni hogyan tudok ebből
ebből úgy kikerülni hogy hogy valamit
valamit hozzáadjon és nem csak magamhoz
hanem mondjuk akár a környezetemhez is